en este vídeo vamos a hacer algunas
cosas interesantes lo primero que vamos
a hacer es encontrar una de las
representaciones en series de mayor y
más sencillas la de ea la equis entonces
tomemos fx es igual a la x y lo que hace
que encontrar esta serie sea tan
sencillo es una de las propiedades más
sorprendentes de que la derivada de la
función a la x es ea la x sale entonces
esto es igual a f prima de x es igual a
la segunda derivada en x es igual a la
tercera derivada de evaluada en x y es
igual a pues la que sea a la enésima
derivada en x todas estas son la x
insisto esto es algo loquísimo del
número e lo que nos dice es que la
pendiente de la tangente a la x en
cualquier punto es igual al valor de la
función en ese mismo punto
uff que padre con esto dicho vamos a
calcular la representación en serie de
más gloria
debemos encontrar efe de 0s prima de 0
es de doble prima de cero y así pero es
a la cero
a la cero es simplemente 1 entonces esto
es igual a efe de 0
es igual a efe prima de 0 es igual a y
así sucesivamente a cualquiera de las
derivadas a ver déjame ponerle así la
enésima derivada evaluada en 0 la que
queramos pues y esto es lo que hace que
sea muy directo encontrar la serie de
mag loring de la equis va entonces si
quisiéramos aproximar a la x le voy a
poner por aquí a la x es aproximadamente
igual a esta anotación quiere decir que
nos acercamos más y más a ella la x
conforme vamos sumando más y más
términos entonces nos quedaría efe de 0
efe de 0 a ver lo voy a hacer con otro
color que no haya usado antes aquí ese
rosa y verde entonces voy a usar digamos
amarillo va entonces efe de 0 es igual a
1 luego hay que sumar f prima de 0 por
equis pero fue prima de 0 es también 1
entonces es más x más otra vez un 1 por
x al cuadrado entre 2 factoriales más x
al cuadrado entre 2 factorial más otro 1
todos estos son unos verdad 11 otro 1 y
en este necesitamos pues también tenemos
un 1 lo único que nos queda es x al cubo
entre 3 factorial más x al cubo entre 3
factorial creo que ya más o menos sobre
el patrón vamos a ponerle más x a la 4
entre 4 factorial más x a la 5 entre 5
factorial más x a la sexta entre 6
factorial más y así sucesivamente y algo
que es muy padre de esta representación
es lo siguiente que bueno número uno
esto está muy padre verdad que era la x
puede ser aproximado por uno más
x mas x al cuadrado entre 2 factoriales
más x al cubo entre 3 factorial una vez
más era la x parece ser que es una
función así súper buena pero esto lleva
a otros resultados interesantes por
ejemplo si quisiéramos aproximar
a más y entonces hay que ponerle aquí x
igual a 1 entonces obtendríamos lo
siguiente sería aproximadamente igual a
bueno y es a la 1 y la 1 es
aproximadamente igual a este polinomio
evaluado en 1 como x es igual a 1
tenemos que sustituir x igual a 1 en
todas partes y entonces tendríamos uno
más uno más uno al cuadrado o sea uno
entre dos factorial más un al cubo o sea
uno entre tres factorial más uno entre
cuatro factorial y así sucesivamente
podríamos seguir sumando una infinidad
de términos fíjate este de aquí podemos
verlo también como 1 entre 1 factorial
bueno déjame borrar esto pero lo que
está realmente padre es que esta es una
forma muy muy bonita de representar ahí
a mí me parece súper padre que sea dos
más uno entre dos factores más uno entre
tres factorial y así sucesivamente que
estas fracciones se aproximen a él es
espectacular pero la emoción no se queda
aquí aún queda algo fascinante por ver
mira vamos acá arriba y vamos a ver las
representaciones de más gloria
de las funciones trigonométricas vamos a
copiar y pegar la de coseno de x y la de
seno de x entonces déjame elegirla con
todo el nombre hasta acá
entonces vamos a copiar vamonos acá
abajo le ponemos pegar
ahí está coseno de equis y ahora vamos
por seno de x entonces
aquí tomamos en o de equis estas
representaciones las encontramos en el
vídeo pasado entonces edición copiar y
ahora vamos acá abajo edición pegar
listo entonces ves algo en común entre
las representaciones de mayor índice no
coseno y x pues estas dos si se ven muy
relacionadas pero qué pasa con la x lo
que vemos es lo siguiente mira coseno de
x se ve mucho como este término con este
término pero con un signo negativo
entonces tendría que ser un menos equis
cuadrada entre dos factorial más este de
acá más una versión negativa de este
término de acá ahora por otro lado en
seno de x seno de x se parece mucho a
este término más una versión negativa de
este término
más este término más una versión
negativa de éste y así sucesivamente y
entonces si pudiéramos arreglar los
signos negativos de alguna manera
interesante o creativa parecería hacer
que a la x ésta de alguna forma o bueno
al menos su representación polinomio de
alguna forma relacionada con una
combinación de las representaciones
polinomiales de coseno de x y de seno de
x esto se está poniendo súper súper
súper loco en empezamos a ver una
conexión entre algo que tiene que ver
con interés compuesto o bien una función
cuya deriva de ella misma y estas cosas
que vienen del círculo unitario que son
cosas trigonométricas parece ser que hay
algunas conexiones en el fondo que son
muy interesantes pero bueno vamos a
dejarle así en el siguiente vídeo no te
pierdas de cómo reconciliar estas tres
fascinantes funciones